hot breath but he says so your last
album
the worst kind of thoughtful which is a
killer album runs about an hour
20 minutes with everyone generally
shooting for 45 to 60 minutes for an
album
was there a reason to go long or are you
that happy with the material
um i was just i was looking to put
something i was looking to put out all
the material that i had
i was just looking to put it all out um
i
um i wanted to get it documented and out
so that i didn't have to
because i'm going to turn it over i know
i'm going to turn it over so
uh and i'm going to move forward in
order to do that i don't want to lose
any of it
so i could have probably done a double
album uh
i think i had enough to do a double
album but i um
just chose to put it all on one thing
and just give it to like
siriusxm and let them play it and uh so
that was my
my mindset was just getting the material
out getting it documented
and moving on in retrospect i should
have shot it
i should have shot it also but in 2008
things are moving fast and no one was
putting out the clips like they are now
so what i should have done is shot it
and then put it out
on siriusxm and then released the clips
incrementally is what i should have done
is that what you're going to find over
and over again that's what i would do
but the whole goal to answer the
question yeah was to get the material
documented
get it out and get it making some money
for me
which was on serious which you're
getting the residuals from that were
like the best way to make money on it
yeah
because how i find that's and i hear
that's how
comics make mostly their money is
through those residuals like
sales or anything like that like did you
find any
useful ways to actually market the album
that you're able to get drive sales of
it
just getting on a podcast podcast was a
good one podcast and letting people know
about it and then having other comics
um vouch for the album guys guys with uh
who are respected and guys with bigger
followings to be like you got to check
this guy's album
and a lot of my good friends did that
for me oh you know ari shafir was the
guy who did it burke chrysler did it
david tell um people that i uh
respect and looked up to jay okerson dan
soder those guys
all like um promoted it
and said yeah this guy's got a really
good album you might not know who you
know you might not know him
but comics know him so listen to his
album and
i've gotten a lot of positive feedback
and a lot of people buying the album
because of it